afternoon a procession made its way
through our streets in honor of
detective justin terry as the department
and his family mourn his loss madison
kimbrough joining us live now at metro
headquarters with more on the detective
madison
as mentioned earlier terry was on duty
when that beam fell on his car now after
the crash word traveled fast that he was
with metro and that he was described as
a well-respected detective dozens of
police motorcycles and cars escorted his
body from the crash site to the clark
county coroner's office near ulta and
rancho shortly after one this afternoon
according to metro terry was assigned to
the homicide sex crimes bureau sexual
assault and abuse section joining metro
in 2001 he started the enduro program at
southeast area command making it
possible for officers to ride dirt bikes
in areas to reach the homeless he was
also assigned to the sexual offender
apprehension detail and worked with the
u.s marshals task force here at metro
headquarters the flags have been lowered
to half staff in terry's honor terry
leaves behind his wife and two sons
reporting live near mlk and ulta madison
kimbrough live local now